[Music]
then is it cheating news Oh Victor Tina
asked right right right right
no no right let's listen to the details
I think it's good to know the rules and
the lines and the games and the plays
and the rules and the place but you have
to know the rules so you know when to
break the rules
hey submitted by visit Toronto Jesus
Christ it's like Toronto like the
official board of Toronto it sounds like
that they love us out there we can't
help it
I like Toronto we should all go we've
been to Canada hey I'm in Montreal they
all speak French that's like the France
of Canada I want to go there too I liked
it so much I think it deserves the title
of America's hat a writer discusses
micro cheating and when it crosses the
line is this like when you get your
scantron and then you erase the thing
and then you do another bubble I think
it's more like when the when a guy tells
a white lie like do I look fat in this
and then they're just like no and he's
like your micro cheating you know like
all right like do you look at that girl
no who's they like president of micro
cheating if I jacked off to a downtown
LA mannequin is that micro cheating oh
wait who comes up with these [ __ ]
turns I do anything that's micro or
aggression I want to [ __ ] ever
what is it automatic is another word
yeah those [ __ ] microwaves in the
movie I think we live in the generation
of overthinking and everything
everything needs a label yeah you got to
put everything in the box [ __ ] hate
it I think we're running out of things
to be offended by well you're not
cheating on me but you were micro
cheating and that hurts still I'm not
triggered there's not enough supply but
there's a [ __ ] ton of demand for [ __ ]
that offends you and so they have to
create supply you know what I think cuz
we just all like feel shitty and we're
like I need an excuse to feel shitty so
we like find something to feel [ __ ] or
to justify yeah feeling shitty it's like
oh it's because of this yeah hey don't
shame feeling shitty
there you go imma make it imma make it
really sad I'm gonna make it really
really sad do it is because the public
is overworking that's what I was gonna
do they don't have time for family and
friends yeah and the way that they
connect is artificially through the
internet and dopamine homie now yeah and
they're they're just constant control
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that they watch so they
just go in this rabbit hole of
negativity and then now they think the
whole world is negative when it's not
also like America more so than any other
country yeah when I go to other
countries I don't feel tense yeah like
I'm just chilling that's so true because
you know it's like I'm on vacation too
but it's also the city were in how if
you leave la it's wait chill right way
too when I visit just his dad out in
Texas he lives in a little town and it's
so chill and I feel like Snow White
because like there's little beard
chillin and there's nothing beautiful
yeah then the minute you go into
comments
it's feeling super sensitive everywhere
international use that yeah I definitely
know that no I've actually been telling
keep saying like man just recently I'm
just like okay and it's cause like I'm
always looking at headlines constantly
for jakie news and I'm always like yeah
the world's it's depressing cuz that's
all of you publish yeah that's why I
don't watch the news a lot of it is just
to get you like fired up anyway like
emotionally I [ __ ] get it it's the
[ __ ] pharmaceuticals yeah
she's right it's smoky because if we're
all sad we all need a medication that
would feel happy the pharmaceuticals are
working with the media outlets they make
us depressed
[ __ ] Google it dude a lot of these
things are co-owned by the same
companies like the pharmaceutical
companies the media companies my hey
it's this new drugs tight you should
check out this new drug is helping you
you feel bad this new drugs tight what
it won't Brazil free my co-chair she
yeah what is Mike Rowe chief so this
dating expert her name is Melanie she
what makes her an expert was she dated a
lot of people and then she got certified
like what sort of fight [ __ ] you can't
say [ __ ] anymore dude you have to say in
the pause no you can own it she's a [ __ ]
she's a [ __ ]
okay float don't slut-shame you can't do
that anymore
he said sloop dude okay well I heard the
first I think the most important thing
is her name because Schillings is like
old school money yeah so Melanie
Schilling
she's a dating expert and what makes her
a dating expert is apparently she's a
relationship strategist and she says
that micro cheating is a series of
seemingly small actions that indicate a
person is emotionally or physically
focused on someone outside of their
relationship so that's what micro
cheating is so it's emotional cheating I
guess what they're saying is that been
around just this lady just wants to make
her in a name for herself no I'm saying
it's been invented already I already has
it my arm it already has a name what is
it yeah I guess I I see your point yeah
I'm calling it micro cheating actually
makes it dwarf in like the dwarf said
yeah it sounds like Diane cheating it's
like I call it dancing with the devil it
belittles how old that's all it is you
just make that just do a little tango
some examples is like if you have inside
jokes or nicknames with someone other
than your partner that's micro cheating
that is weird
yeah that's pretty weird that happened
in my last relationship and I was made
to feel crazy for it mmm now you know so
you can't have intimate moments with
friends outside of your relationship I
guess the way like when it's micro
cheating it's like you are sort of
interested in that person like this
other example is if you always try to
make an effort to look nice knowing that
you're gonna run into a certain person
outside of your relationship that's
micro cheating or like if they use the
same language that they do with you as a
to another person that's also attractive
you know where like like if I were to
call someone else like my boo or like oh
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
no way you know no if I were to say that
to people like yeah exactly that's like
oh that was like our thing and now
you're just using it wherever I think
yeah there's two things we could
simplify it by one intention and to the
rules of your personal relationship so
if you have a relationship with you know
you just talk it out and see what's cool
within that and in there's
self-regulation where it's like do am I
really trying to flirt with this person
to [ __ ] or am I trying to just get a
little ego trip yeah but I think the ego
trip thing is the same level of hurt for
the partner it is what do you need the
ego trip for like you your partner in
you or satisfying you enough right right
and you can have that conversation too
if you're not exactly a ting enough
validation from your partner like that's
a thing you have to work out or some
people were just flirty flirty you know
they just you know they never last long
and relationships do hmm
they shouldn't even be one in the first
place yeah exactly either commit or
don't yeah yeah yeah the flirts I've
seen a thousand for its flame out it
does sound like that there are people
out there that come off as very flirty
but they're oblivious they're just too
friendly to everybody but it's the guy's
fault
specifically women I think it's the
guy's fault that you take their actions
as oh my gosh he thinks oh for sure and
sometimes they think that it's flirting
they think it's flirting and also I
didn't know that if you use emojis in
text that they automatically think
you're into them or didn't know either
yeah no I didn't yeah and see you - no I
don't know that I didn't know that you
would do it with girls only and I'm like
uh guys - okay well you would do it with
because I thought it was the new
generation of talking me - so I just
started adding emojis - I just told him
I'm like the way you talk to a girl via
text versus the way you talk to guys
like you're gonna make girls feel
uncomfortable cuz he would say like can
I tell you a secret I'm like you don't
[ __ ] say that that comes up right
here that's all there's like a little
winky like I'm like that is weird it's
the same piece of Bart's flirting with
everybody but he doesn't know we kind of
validation but you need Bart yeah he's a
flirt dude yeah that could go off weird
yes I can see if girls don't reply to
him I'm like yeah cuz they think you're
hitting on them but you're not like it's
just you don't know any better yeah the
other the person on the receiving end is
like whoa this guy is [ __ ] weird and
he's married oh he's like yo can I tell
you see her and he's like you're late to
work another movie yeah because a lot of
miscommunication happens - yeah because
people I could totally see relationships
and couples people using this as a
to like kind of control their
significant other and like be like
because they're just [ __ ] jealous and
they don't want them to communicate with
anyone else but like you're a [ __ ]
micro cheating on me yeah you've just
new to be secure with their relationship
like what like if you were secured with
the relationship like Steve can go to a
strip club I'm not scared at all that's
like if I caught just sucking dick I
wouldn't be all faced by it you know
because I'm secure I'm like listen to
cheat on yeah yes they have trust walk
in and I'll be like oh hey babe love you
what's up Rick how you doing man mmm and
you shake his hand right hey what's that
what's up and then it's like oh they
must be they must be great friends you
know it's because like I don't know so
there's no such thing as cheating
because it could be a platonic [ __ ]
it's a break a [ __ ] no no it's
because I know she loves me and that's
that's all that matters and long she
doesn't love anyone else some people are
like that oh I don't know I don't even
know like I'm blind to the cheating
that's that's the thing so people
separate sex and love I don't want to
have sex with nobody
I'm just saying that's how much I trust
her I would lie to myself if I saw her
[ __ ] somebody in my house
eggnog there's no way this could be
happening I'm just like you know trust
your own eyeballs no I want my eyes are
lying dude this is you're doing this on
purpose miss you do you're getting it on
video you saying all the ships so that
one day if you catch her with somebody
and you murder everything in the room
you got a nice little video for your
defense
oh you can't pull it fast I'm just I'm
just sweet because I believe everything
but I do agree that you have to be on
the same terms as your partner because
I'd say that Steve's the first person
that we have the same idea of how our
relationship would run because like my
ex-boyfriends I mean I consider it to be
shitty to reach out to a girl
when you're in a relationship reach out
to another girl and say hey you're
really cute let's meet up or some [ __ ]
like that but they say it's not like
business talked oh yeah that doesn't
sound like micro cheating that sounds
like cheating you know me and Nikki see
eye to eye like really on everything
it's like for me it's like I just have
two rules keep my balls empty in my
belly full you don't talk about baby by
yourself and that's fill your rule
that's [ __ ] scary well that is a good
rule that even my size can do that by
them I know they can but I'm scared for
him we don't need you be afraid we don't
need you if you do the thing you've
always wanted to do and learn how to
select your own dick then that would
always be true and I wouldn't have to do
anything I know but I have a bad back I
know that you don't want your back to
give out and you're also pretty tall I
think if you were to remove a vertebra
you could probably do it right didn't
didn't somebody do hidden prints - its
Marilyn Monroe did No Manson man Monroe
could suck her own dick right yeah I
think she's like the other people say oh
that's what it was
I know is it that stuff
[Music]
[Music]